boy oh boy or things getting crazy with
Donald Trump and Russia where to even
start remember when all of a sudden the
Republican Party shifted during July of
2016 the summer the heart of the
presidential campaign from what was four
years a very strongly anti Russia stand
to a much more friendly stance towards
Russia
we now have leaked memos and a timeline
that we put together exposed by these
memos which suggests that there was no
coincidence at all about the Republican
and trumpian change with perspective on
with respect to Russia but rather a
coordinated quid pro quo between the
Trump I mean at the time it was the
Trump campaign and Russia one of the
pieces of information from the leaked
dossier about Trump opposition research
exposes this in significant detail and
the thing is even if you still don't
believe the dossier itself right the the
publicly knowable timeline serves to
corroborate and I'll explain and then
we'll discuss as we know this dossier
was part of an opposition research
project conducted by a former British
spy Christopher Steele originally at the
request of anti Trump Republicans and
later by Democrats and what Christopher
Steele found out and alleged in this
dossier is that Donald Trump would stop
speaking forcefully against Russia
specifically about Russia's incursion
into Ukraine and in exchange this is the
quid pro quo part Russia would provide
WikiLeaks the documented stole from the
DNC last week separately we found out
about the existence of intermediaries
between Russia and week WikiLeaks you'll
remember that Julian Assange said our
contact was not someone a Russian
elected official or state agent or actor
and we now have identified that there's
an intermediary that was in place which
makes the letter of what Julian Assange
that Julian Assange said but certainly
not the spirit of it if your argument is
well none of this is true because
there's nothing public that corroborates
it you could not be more wrong what we
know we know because many of this
many of these statements and at
assertions have been independently
reported or just publicly knowable so
let's put up the timeline and check out
what we now know back in April of 2016
we know that Donald Trump hired Paul
Manafort Paul Manafort was a sort of
consultant that was working for that to
install a pro-russian government in
Ukraine he was found to have received an
off-the-books multi-million dollar
payment his ties to Russia were
discovered and he resigned but
immediately after the hiring of Paul
Manafort we saw the Trump campaign
language on Russia change just before
July 18th of 2016 all of a sudden the
Trump team demand changes to Republican
Russia policy now what's fascinating is
that Trump was at odds with Republican
orthodoxy on a number of issues but the
only issue on which Trump operative
actually had the Republican stance
changed remember right before the
Republican National Convention was the
issue of Russia and Russia's quote
military aggression in Ukraine there are
already too many smoking guns for any
reasonable person to believe that there
was no coordination at all between
Russia and the Trump campaign but it
actually goes on on July 21st of 2016
there is a Los Angeles Times article
which points out in a shift Republican
platform doesn't call for arming Ukraine
against Russia spurring outrage the
opening line of that LA Times article
reading for decades Republican doctrine
has viewed Russia as a power to mistrust
but in Donald Trump's GOP Moscow sins
seem to matter less and the day after
that pad July 22nd 2016 WikiLeaks
publishes the first emails stolen from
the DNC 44 thousand emails nearly 18,000
attachments and as we know through
October of 2016 Donald Trump denied the
formal accusation of Russia
as having been behind the hacks in
December of 2016 Michael Flynn Trump's
incoming national security adviser was
in touch with the Russian ambassador and
also in December of 2016 Donald Trump
appointed the Russia connected Rex
Tillerson as Secretary of State
meanwhile right-wingers want pizza gate
investigated you to some pictures on
Instagram you don't even have to believe
the Trump blackmail file dossier thing
just look at the public timeline of
events here yeah there was so many
moments during this campaign where we
found it bizarre that Donald Trump was
speaking so highly of Russia and
Vladimir Putin yeah and we thought maybe
at the time it just had to deal with the
fact that Putin's a strongman
authoritarian appeal now not the much
deeper connections here hello your
response is going to be the Trump
dossier is fake news you're missing the
point you don't need to believe anything
in the dossier to see and understand
this timeline all of which is sourced
independently of that alleged blackmail
file we have every indication that we
have a puppet of the Russians incoming
as president of the United States thanks
for watching this video before you watch
the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated